Donald Trump still thinks that the  Central Park five are guilty  something I've criticized quite a bit  about there's no question you know that  that aspect or I should say that event  in the campaign made me want to tear out  what little hair I have left but at the  same time had the lowest unemployment  rate among african-americans and  Hispanic Americans than ever in US  history do you think on some level  higher higher do you think on some level  he knows that they didn't do it and it's  just at a point now where it's like once  you're dug in it's kind of hard to go  okay I was wrong he's very very stubborn  decision least one more Jim and Sam  catch up with full episodes and  interviews from celebrity guests anytime  on demand using the Sirius XM f  [Music]